the growing number of alleged sexual
assault survivors are publicly sharing
their stories the outpouring is in
response to president Trump's criticism
of Supreme Court nominee Brett
Cavanaugh's accuser Christine Blasi ford
claims Kavanaugh sexually assaulted her
in high school which he denies the
hashtag why I didn't report started
trending on social media after the
president questioned was he Ford's
credibility he tweeted quote if the
attack on dr. Ford was as bad as she
says charges would have been immediately
filed but survivors say it's just not
that easy it never occurred to me really
until many years later that it was rape
I thought this was something that was
entirely my fault
author Diane Chamberlain says it took
five decades to share her story of
sexual assault which occurred when she
was 18 years old she says she didn't
even tell her best friend I would have
told her everything
so that's sort of a sign of just how
ashamed I was of putting myself in that
position chamberlain was one of more
than 700 20,000 people women and men who
took to Twitter this weekend using the
hashtag why I didn't report among them
me to advocate an actress Alyssa Milano
whose tweet has been shared more than
16,000 times I was sexually assaulted
twice once when I was a teenager I never
filed a police report and it took me 30
years to tell my parents
many listed reasons why they kept quiet
because I knew it was his word against
mine because I'm still afraid
psychologist Don Hughes rape and sexual
assault and victimization in general is
vastly underreported to authorities
seven out of ten victims do not report
rapes and other assaults to police the
same percentage actually know their
attacker Hugh says that can make it more
difficult for them to come forward fear
that isn't you're not going to be taken
seriously and then you're going to be
the target you're going to be shamed and
humiliated and sometimes that
cost-benefit analysis is just too much
to bear for a victim chamberlain hopes
the current wave of people speaking up
will empower the next generation i hope
that the conversation were have
now would enable teenage girls today to
know that they do need to turn to
authorities instead of my generation
just living with this horror
we should note that since that hashtag
why I didn't report start of the
organization that runs the national
sexual assault hotline says it saw a 42%
increase in phone calls that's compared
to an average Friday or Saturday that's
why this story is so important or that
you're putting it in that perspective
because anyone who has been through this
totally understands why women don't come
forward and I think people find it
egregious including the President of the
United States his tweet that over the
weekend where he said well why didn't
she come forward or why didn't her
loving parents say something because you
were afraid you won't be believed you're
an embarrassed and ashamed
on some level many women think it was
their fault which is absolutely not true
and in talking to somebody who was
affected by that tweeting it reached
down into a very white-hot response and
so there's all the details really
tumbling out no matter how far how long
it's been interesting that it my voice
does not matter yes what happened to me
does not matter and that's what's
changing is that my voice does matter